Captain America 3 Civil War is the best
Marvel Cinematic Universe movie to date
and here's why
number one it does not feel like a
Marvel Cinematic Universe movie I always
felt like one of the biggest problems
with the MCU movies up to this point was
that they felt exactly like comic-book
movies
sure they had great heroes like Captain
America or Iron Man and were a blend of
fanservice and traditional action films
where the plots were oftentimes a little
thin and the villains were forgettable
and undeveloped largely using one-liners
during their final battles looking back
to Thunderbolt Ross Malick Darren cross
and Obadiah Stane the bane of the MCS
existence seemed to be that Marvel
didn't know how to handle their villains
or build them into something special
maybe this was based on the idea of
simply having someone there for the
heroes to fight but whatever the reason
I can't sit back and say that the
previous MCU movies had villains that
could stand as someone identifiable for
even intriguing on a basic level with
civil war it's not that way while the
movie does focus on a rift between the
Avengers and the formation of Captain
America's Secret Avengers this is really
just one piece of a larger puzzle the
sokovia accords Bucky Barnes and black
panther all stand as consequences of the
Ultron battle in Avengers 2 by the
introduction of spider-man and the
Easter eggs of future Marvel heroes and
the cinematic universe our resolve of
the Avengers formation along with the
world becoming aware of super-powered
beings like the Hulk Thor Steve Rogers
and Scarlet Witch indeed while Civil War
did leave me walking away with a kind of
finality in terms of the Avengers team
it also reins to the words of Nick Fury
in the post-credits scene of Iron Man 1
when he informed stark that he was part
of a much bigger world he just didn't
know it yet considering that this film
is the official start of phase 3 in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
much like Tony in those final moments I
walked out of the theater with the
feeling that everything was about to
change number 2
Black Panther and spider-man when Marvel
announced that the charla would be
joining the cast of Civil War as well as
the POE Sony deal announcement of Peters
inclusion I was a little concerned at
their introductions would be ad hoc and
that they would literally just feel like
tacked on characters for the sole
purpose of advertising things to come
and Phase three instead their
participation in the movie felt 100%
organic
Tom Holland played spider-man
beautifully and came across as the young
Peter Parker we would expect to see if
his character had originally been owned
and produced in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
at the same time chadwick boseman played
black panther in an incredible way while
not as intense or hardened as to chala
from the comics he was impressive
nonetheless and was a great blend
between the flat Panther we know from
the Marvel Universe and the more
realistic depiction of his character in
the MCU in addition to this his
involvement did not overshadow the
overarching story of civil war or the
events contained within he had a purpose
and he acted on that purpose but his
character also fought when he needed to
and didn't fight when he didn't need to
while the accidents were a little off
that complaint is hardly even worth
mentioning in the face of how well his
character was portrayed number 3 ant men
so let's get this out of the way right
now
I loved ant-man I know some people
thought it was lackluster in comparison
to what we had seen so far and felt like
the quality was on par with Iron Man 1
instead of the Winter Soldier however I
thought Paul Rudd played an amazing
Scott Lang ended a fantastic job of
portraying a father stuck in a hard
situation that said I wasn't really
skeptical so much as curious as to how
his character would be included in the
overarching civil war story without
offering any spoilers I think I can get
away with saying that Scott's
involvement is on the same level as
spider-man but he absolutely elevated
the airport battle scene from something
interesting to something extraordinary
the hero he displayed in the ant-man
movie remains but there's also a little
fanservice with the oh my god you're
Captain America moments and truth I
think Scott Lang could have used a
little more time in the movie especially
after the events of the airport battle
but this is really just personal
preference and did not take away from
the movie in my eyes as a whole in any
form or fashion number 4 it's Captain
America's movie so after seeing age of
Ultron
I think Marvel moviegoers were left with
a bit of a bad taste in their mouth
regarding what happens when multiple
heroes are thrown into a single movie
with a ton of hot threads whether this
was a byproduct of the difference
between the directing styles of Joss
Whedon and the Russo brothers or their
ability to craft a story is a question
that I don't have the answer to but I
will say that those concerns will be
thrown off
the window with this movie while the
feeling of age of Ultron came with the
fact that there was just too much going
on and film did not know what it wanted
to be civil war is clear on what it is a
Captain America film or the entire cast
of Avengers plus a few others are all in
this movie the main light is shine on
Rogers with everyone else being
ancillary characters now well I don't
mean that they are unimportant what I do
mean is that their roles in the film
serve to support Roger stance on why
he's right were wrong indeed the debate
in Avengers mansion between the team on
whether or not a sokovia accords should
be signed or ignored spends much of its
time focusing on Rogers reactions to
people's stance and actually seems more
like a roundtable discussion leaving us
as a viewer to ask what do you do when
you have to make the choice of valuing
freedom versus security furthermore the
involvement of Bucky Barnes and Peggy
Carter highlight the very idea that
despite having surrounded himself by
modern-day individuals whom he's come to
view as friends and allies and a lot of
ways
Rogers cannot let go of the past and
looks to Peggy and Bucky as the only
people he can ever truly trust where
this does evolve over the course of a
film and he seems to be catching up with
the modern day overall the Russos
maintained the idea that for better or
worse Rogers is still a man stuck in the
past using his experiences with the
Nazis to recognize that humans are
capable of incredible and terrible
things but these ideas are a byproduct
of freedom a principle which he argues
should never be compromised on
regardless of how its implementation may
affect the rest of the world number 5
Tony Stark so yes this is clearly a
Captain America film and was written to
Center on Steve Rogers view of the world
but damn it of Robert Downey jr. is
amazing where previous movies have seen
Rogers and stark butting heads on
different issues
I feel like Robert Downey jr. has sat
down read every single issue of Civil
War absorb that information and
translated it into his portrayal of Iron
Man in this movie the sidetrack here
the beauty of Tony Stark's predicament
in the comics was a struggle he faced
between recognizing if Civil War was a
no-win situation as one of the smartest
men in the world alongside Reed Richards
and white panther on the whole to trauma
remain uninvolved
in the comics threatening war against
shield should they try to impose
regulation on Wakanda while reads kept
his head in the ground of science
designing prison 42 to house both heroes
and villains who refused to register for
start on the other hand his turmoil came
in the realization that without some
form of oversight the events of Days of
Future past or some similar future were
guaranteed to come to fruition in the
society would eventually turn against
heroes dude is slowly coming to the
belief that their desire to defeat
villains overrode the concern for
civilians looking to keep it from
happening
stark operated as the figurehead of
regulation and the eventual director of
shield all while realizing this civil
war had created a rift in the Marvel
Universe that could never be completely
repaired much like those comics the
civil war movie throws Tony in
opposition to Rogers asking the question
of what uses freedom to a society that
would use that freedom to destroy itself
as a result Stark's position of
realizing that there's no way to win
this war per se goes forward unabashed
under the idea that heroes needing to
operate with oversight was a necessity
while both stark strict adherence to
registration and Rogers strict adherence
to freedom both have their own drawbacks
the Russos did an incredible job of
presenting those dichotomies in a way
that resulted in some incredible
arguments between the two and creating a
fracture in their friendship that would
change the way each views the other
forever so having said all of that can
the civil war movie be compared
adequately to the Civil War comic well
the answer to that question is that a
cannot simply because a Civil War event
spanned over the course of a year ran
along over 100 comics and involved the
entire roster of Marlowe's heroes -
mutants however for the movie being what
it is in the Avengers roster and
Marvel's lineup being as limited as it
is civil war was a fantastic movie and
really through the idea in the question
regarding the American people and how we
in the real world view ourselves in
relation to the argument of freedom
versus security with that being said
we're gonna bring this review to an end
I hope you guys enjoyed it and post your
thoughts down in the comment section did
you guys love Civil War or did you guys
hate Civil War and now we'll catch you
guys later peace